ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BASED
BANKER FORGES BRADFORD CABALLERO
QUARTET THE DALLY DODD TO
ROSSELL A GIVEN BLAZER GONZALEZ
ROBERT HERTZBERG WHEN I FOUND
HER TADO. JONES CAM AUGER
LAYERED FLAVOR LEMON MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S MIN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
SHOW OF PAN FORTINO RALPH RUBIO
SKINNER TERN AMBERG BY KATHY.
WEINER WELL. MEMBERS THE QUORUM
IS PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE REALM AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER. THIS AFTERNOON
BY SENATOR ADMIN AFTER WHICH
WILL ASK YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
AND WE'LL BE LETTING PLEDGE BY
SENATOR NEWMAN DIRECTOR. ROBERT
YOU HAVE IT YEAH. IS MADE UP.
THE SENATE GATHERS TODAY WITH
OUR HEADS BOWED IN OUR HEARTS
STRONG AS WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY
AND ASK FOR BLESSINGS FOR ALL OF
THOSE UNDER ATTACK IN OUR WORLD
MAY BE WITH US MICHY CS TO OUR
GLORY. AMEN. COLLEGE PLEASE JOIN
ME IN RECITING THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
MEMBERS WERE
READY TO BEGIN MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE TEAM READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WE
WILL BE TEAM READ REPORTS IN
COMMITTEE WE'LL BE DOING READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. BRAVO
OF THE SENATE JOURNAL WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR FEBRUARY. TWENTY ONE TO
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRETED BY
THE MINUTE CLERK. K. FOUR
MOMENTS MOTIONS. TO ADOPT A
MAN'S. HERE CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. WE HAVE APPOINTMENT
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT WE HAVE
ITEMS THREE AND FOUR SENATOR
BAITS ARE YOU PREPARED. WHEN
YOU'RE READY CENTER DEBATE YOU
MAY BEGIN AND MANY. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- WE HAVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE WHICH IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF IDA. A STATE
ARCHITECT OF DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES DIVISION OF THE
STATE PARK HERE. MISS CLAIRE
HAVE SERVED AS ACTING STATE
ARCHITECT SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN
SHE IS A CALIFORNIA LICENSED
ARCHITECT IT IS ALSO CERTIFIED
ACCESS SPECIALIST IN A
LEADERSHIP IN ENERGY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL DESIGN ACCREDITED
PROFESSIONAL SHE WAS APPROVED IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY THIRD ON A FIVE. ZERO
VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT.
HERE IN NC NINE MINUTES
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CALL ITEM THREE. ALAN ARCHULETA%
R. I. ATKINS I HATE. FIVE BACKER
HI FORGES HI BRADFORD I HAVE A
HYPERTENSIVE HI DOLLY. FIVE DOT
FIVE TORONTO HI EGGMAN I LATER
FIVE CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROVE. HI
HURTS BERG FIVE WEST SO. I HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER HI
LAYERED I LABOR. I THE MON HI
WIRE. I MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN
I NELSON I UNTIL A BOGEY I PAN.
HI FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS. I RUBIO
I SKINNER. HI STERN HI I'M BURKE
HI HI WHITE HOUSE SPEAKING HI
WINNER. HI WELL I PLEASE CALL
AFTER MEMBER ALAN HI. HIGHS
FORTY NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FOLLOW ITEM FOR SENATOR GREAT.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF THE FOLLOWING APPOINTEES TO
THE ACUPUNCTURE BOARD DR YANG
PEEING CHAN. JOHN HARI BEDIA
FRANCISCO KIM AND DR AMY PATAKI.
THESE APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY THIRD ON A FIVE
ZERO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ARRIVAL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
APPOINTMENT. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ABATE HEARING TEAM
NINE MINUTES SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CALL ITEM FOR.
ALAN I ARCHULETA. FIVE ADKINS I
FACE. FIVE BECKER. I PORCHES HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A ITEM ID FOR
TESTING I DALLY. I THOUGHT I
TORONTO HI AIKMAN HI PLEASE SIR
I CONSOLIDATE I GROW. I HEARD
SPURRED HI WESTOVER. TIDO I
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOR I LIVE ALONE HI WIRE. I
MELINDA'S FIVE MIN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I WENT TO A VOTE I CAN.
HI FORTINO HI ROB HI RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN HI NUMBER HI WE
CASKEY I WINNER HI WELL I.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THAT'S A
MEMBER. YES SIR I. HIGHS FORTY
KNOWS ZERO APPOINTMENTS ARE
CONFIRMED NOW MEMBERS RETURNING
BACK TO MOTIONS OR RESOLUTIONS
NOW IS THE TIME FOR OUR JOURNEY
MEMORIES MEMBERS IF YOU'RE
PREPARED FIRST UP WE HAVE CENTER
AT ATKINS. MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A
BELOVED EDUCATOR AND A CHAMPION
OF EQUALITY IN THE SAN DIEGO
REGION AND BEYOND MISS DOROTHY
L. W. SMITH. DOROTHY WAS THE
FIRST BLACK WOMAN ELECTED TO
PUBLIC OFFICE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY HAVING SERVED ON THE SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL BOARD FOR
EIGHT YEARS. AND AS ITS
PRESIDENT TWICE. SHE PASSED AWAY
ON FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTY TWO BUT HER LEGACY OF
WORK TO IMPROVE TEACHING AND
MAKE IT MORE EQUITABLE FOR
STUDENTS INDOORS. DOROTHY WAS
BORN IN CAPITAL BILL TENNESSEE
IN NINETEEN THIRTY NINE. DESPITE
DISCRIMINATION AND ATTENDING A
SEGREGATED SCHOOL FOR BLACK
STUDENTS SHE HELD FAST TO THE
STRENGTH HER PARENTS EXUDE. AND
THE MINDSET THAT AS LONG AS YOU
HAVE CONTROL OF YOUR MIND NO ONE
COULD DO ANYTHING TO HURT YOU.
SHE GRADUATED VALEDICTORIAN FROM
HIGH SCHOOL AND ATTENDED THE ALL
BLACKS PHILANDER SMITH COLLEGE
IN LITTLE ROCK ARKANSAS. LATER
MARRYING HER COLLEGE LOVE CORAL
AND MOVING TO CLEVELAND WHERE
SHE GRADUATED FROM CASE WESTERN
RESERVE UNIVERSITY. WITH A
DEGREE IN ENGLISH SHE BEGAN
TEACHING HIGH SCHOOL AND IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA AND STARTED TEACHING
AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN LONG
BEACH IN EL CAJON. LUCKILY FOR
OUR COMMUNITY DOROTHY THEN WOUND
UP IN SAN DIEGO TEACHING ENGLISH
AND AFRICAN AMERICAN LITERATURE
AT SAN DIEGO CITY COLLEGE WHERE
SHE WAS A PROFESSOR FOR TWENTY
FOUR YEARS. SHE ALSO SERVED AS A
LECTURER AT SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE DOROTHY WAS APPOINTED AND
THEN ELECTED TO THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL BOARD. IT WAS
DURING THAT TIME THAT SHE PUSHED
TO RECALIBRATE HIGH SCHOOL
COURSES SO AS TO LIFT THE
QUALITY OF TEACHING AND THE
CURRICULUM. INCLUDING REMOVING
CLASSES THAT DIDN'T MEET COLLEGE
ENTRANCE REQUIREMENTS AND
COURSES THAT DIDN'T COUNT
TOWARDS HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION.
DOROTHY HELPED FOUND THE MCGILL
SCHOOL OF SUCCESS CHARTER SCHOOL
IN SOUTH PARK IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX. AND WAS THE INAUGURAL
LEADER OF A PROGRAM TO HELP
INCREASE DIVERSITY WITHIN SAN
DIEGO STATE'S TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM. IN HER
SPARE TIME SHE WAS A REVERED
HOME COOK. A BOARD MEMBER OF
COMMON GROUND THE OLDEST BLACK
THEATER COMPANY IN SAN DIEGO.
SHE HELPED WITH CHRIST UNITED
PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH'S AFTER
SCHOOL TUTORING PROGRAM. AND WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST MEMBERS AND
PRESIDENTS OF THE SAN DIEGO
ETHICS COMMISSION THAT WE HELPED
FORM IN SAN DIEGO IN TWO
THOUSAND. WHERE THERE WAS A NEED
IN THE COMMUNITY SHE FILLED IT
AND WHEN THERE WAS A NEED TO
UPLIFT AND ENCOURAGE STUDENTS IN
THE CLASSROOM SHE FILLED IT TEN
FOLD. EQUITY WAS HER FOCAL POINT
ESPECIALLY FOR BLACK AND LATINO
STUDENTS WHO WERE NOT BEING
GIVEN ENOUGH OPPORTUNITIES AND
ACCESS. HER PHILOSOPHY WAS THAT
EVERY STUDENT NO MATTER THEIR
BACKGROUND CAN SUCCEED. HER
REACHING IMPACT WAS VAST
EVIDENCED BY NOT ONLY THE LEGACY
SHE LEAVES IN OUR SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY. BUT THEN IN THE
OUTPOURING OF ADMIRATION
FOLLOWING HER PASSING. SHE'S
BEEN MEMORIALIZED TODAY IN THE
ASSEMBLY AS WELL BY OUR
COLLEAGUE DR A Q. A WEB OF.
DOROTHY WAS A MENTOR TO OUR
SECRETARY OF STATE DR SHIRLEY
WEBER. WHO WROTE THAT DOROTHY
WAS A WARRIOR AND COMRADE IN THE
STRUGGLE FOR JUSTICE EQUALITY
AND DIGNITY. SHE WAS THE BEST OF
BLACK WOMANHOOD WRAPPED UP IN
ONE PERSON. WE ARE ALL BETTER
FOR HER. ALSO DOROTHY WAS ONE OF
THE THREE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ENCOURAGE DR SHIRLEY WEBER TO
RUN FOR THE CITY GO SCHOOL
BOARD. WHERE SHE INTERNED SERVED
AS PRESIDENT. AND THAT'S WHERE I
MET SHIRLEY WEBER WHAT AN
INCREDIBLE LEGACY THAT DOROTHY
LEFT. SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND CARL HER SON DR CARLTON
SMITH DAUGHTER SHERILYN LOT AND
FOUR GRANDCHILDREN COLLEAGUES I
ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING DOROTHY SMITH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
WE EXTEND OUR MOST SINCERE
CONDOLENCES TO THE SMITH FAMILY
AND ASKED THAT YOU BRING THE
NAME FOR TO COULD BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED I KNOW NO WE- NO
OKAY. NEXT UP WE HAVE SENATOR
MELINDA BUSH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES TERRORIZED HER DURING
THE MEMORY OF DON DECKS- DON WAS
. WELL KNOWN IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
PARTICULARLY IN RIVERSIDE
POLITICS BUT HE WAS CERTAINLY
MORE- THERE'S MORE TO HIM OTHER
THAN POLITICS HE WAS FROM
MARYLAND ORIGINALLY BORN IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN. AND DIED
RECENTLY AT THE AGE OF SIXTY
FOUR FROM ALL SORTS OF COLITIS-
IN THEM THE LEGACY HE LEAVES
BEHIND IS BASS HE ANYBODY
INVOLVED IN POLITICS RIVERSIDE
COUNTY KNEW EXACTLY WHO DON WAS
AND HE WAS. VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT HOW HE FELT BUT HE WAS
ALSO VERY RESPECTFUL- TO THOSE
WHO DISAGREED WITH HIM HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS DAUGHTER ALEX
HIS PARTNER ANNETTE POMPEII- AND
I WILL JUST TELL YOU THAT- DON
DIX WAS. THE KIND OF GUY YOU
DEFINITELY WANTED ON YOUR SIDE.
BUT HE WAS A TREMENDOUS FRIEND
HE WAS A KIND AND CARING PERSON.
AND EVER I THINK EVERYONE WAS
VERY VERY SHOCKED WE KNEW HE WAS
SICK FOR A WHILE- BUT CERTAINLY
DID NOT ANTICIPATE HIS DEATH AND
HE WILL BE SORELY MISSED THERE
WILL BE- SERVICES FOR HIM ON
MARCH TWELFTH WHICH- I KNOW
THERE'S GOING TO BE A- VERY
SIGNIFICANT TURNOUT. I'M FOR HIM
TO CELEBRATE HIS LIFE BECAUSE
THERE WAS MUCH TO CELEBRATE
ABOUT DON TEXAS LIFE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE
EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES WE ALSO
HAVE SENATOR ROTH. I'M WISHING
TO SPEAK ON THIS AS WELL THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT- DON DIX WAS A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE. FROM CORONA
CALIFORNIA A GENTLEMAN WHO
PASSED AWAY. WAY WAY TOO YOUNG.
THAT DONE AND I CERTAINLY DIDN'T
AGREE ON EVERYTHING WHEN IT CAME
TO POLITICS IN FACT DEPENDING ON
THE ISSUE PROBABLY NOT MUCH. NO
SURPRISE THERE I GUESS THAT'S
THE NATURE OF THIS BUSINESS THAT
WE'RE ALL IN. BUT THERE ACTUALLY
ARE THINGS BELIEVE IT OR NOT
THAT TRANSCENDS POLITICS.
IMPORTANT THINGS AND DONE AND I
SHARE THOSE WE ALL DO. PRIDE IN
COMMUNITY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT I
BELIEVE IN PEOPLE. PATRIOTISM
AND LOVE OF COUNTRY THOSE ARE
ALL DONE DECKS. AS THEY SAY IN
THE MILITARY DONE DIDN'T SIT IN
THE BACK WITH THE GEAR. HE
DIDN'T SIT IN THE BACK WITH THE
GEAR. HE WAS THE DOER. AND THIS
COMMUNITY WAS MUCH BETTER FOR IT
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS GO OUT
TO HIS FAMILY. AND HE WILL
SORELY BE MISSED THANK YOU THANK
YOU SOONER OFF WE ARE SECURE.
ULTRABOOK ON THIS ITEM AS WELL.
SINNER TROUBLED. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR IN THE FIGHT BEGAN I JUST
WANT TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUES'
COMMENTS. ALTHOUGH DON WAS NOT A
RESIDENT IN MY DISTRICT HE WAS A
PERSON KNOWN AND ADMIRED BY MANY
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE. AND THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY'S REPUBLICAN PARTY HE
MADE IT A PRIORITY TO PERSONALLY
CONNECT WITH PEOPLE. HE WAS
PASSIONATE ABOUT GETTING BORDERS
CIVICALLY ENGAGED AND AS HE PUT
IT HE WANTED PEOPLE TO QUOTE GET
OUT OF THE STANDS AND GET ON TO
THE FIELD OF PLAY. AND QUOTE.
JENNIFER HORN HIS CO HOST ON THE
JANAND DON SHOW. SAID HE WOULD
TALK TO EVERY PERSON HE'S EVER
MET. WHETHER WE WERE AT AN AIR
SHOW OR A RESTAURANT HE INSPIRED
REAL CHANGE BECAUSE HE WAS A
REAL PERSON. I REMEMBER MEETING
HER. DOWN FOR THE FIRST TIME.
HIS RADIO DEEP VOICE. MADE AND
CONVEYED. MADE HIM A POPULAR-
GRAHAM HOST HE WAS ELOQUENT AND
HE WAS VERY WELL READ. HE LOVED
OUR COUNTRY AND THE IDEALS IT
REPRESENTS. HE WORKED DILIGENTLY
TO ENSURE ITS FUTURE SUCCESS.
DON YOUR TENACITY PASSION AND
GENEROSITY WILL ALWAYS BE
REMEMBERED THANK YOU FOR ALL
THAT YOU CONTRIBUTED TO THE
INLAND EMPIRE INTO CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU WE ASK THAT THE NAME
BE BROUGHT FORTH SO HE COULD BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATOR NEXT UP
IS SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I'LL-
HOPE YOU JOIN ME IN REMEMBERING
THE LIFE OF PATRICK W. HENNING
PATRICK WAS THE FOLLOW UP FATHER
OF ONE OF MY FORMER STAFF
MEMBERS MICHAEL HANDING ANY
PASSED AWAY THIS PAST DECEMBER-
AND I SERVED TOGETHER ON HIGH
SPEED RAIL COMMISSION WHERE HE
WAS A PASSION PASSIONATE
DEDICATED SUPPORTER OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL. BUT THOSE OF US HAVE
BEEN AROUND FOR AWHILE MAY
REMEMBER HIM FROM HIS WORK IN
OTHER CAPACITIES HIS CAREER
SPANNED OVER FORTY YEARS IN
LABOR RELATIONS BEGINNING IN
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AS A LABOR
REPRESENTATIVE FOR SEIU HOTEL
RESTAURANT POLICE BARTENDERS
UNION IN LOS ANGELES THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL TWELVE. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE ESSENCE OF HIS
WORK HE SAID WAS COMMON SENSE
JUSTICE DIGNITY AND INHERENT
RIGHTS OF WORKERS. PATRICK
SERVED IN THE STATE. IN MANY
MANY DIFFERENT CAPACITIES
INCLUDING AS THE STATE LABOR
COMMISSIONER IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES UNDER GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN HE ALSO SERVED IN THIS
BUILDING AS STAFF DIRECTOR BOTH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY AS
WELL SENATE LABOR COMMITTEES FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS. LATER GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER APPOINTED- THIS
LONG TIME LABOR LEADER DIRECT
THE STATE'S EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT TWO
THOUSAND FOUR. THESE ARE THE
THINGS THAT HE- WAS PAID FOR BUT
HE WAS ALSO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CATHOLIC LABOR
INSTITUTE OF LOS ANGELES A
MEMBER OF A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS INCLUDING
THE COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN STATE WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
BOARD SERVED AS CHAIR OF THE
STATE'S MULTI AGENCY JOINT
FORSMAN. STRIKE FORCE ON THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY AND
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD SERVING DURING DIFFICULT
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE
FARMWORKER UNIONS AND THEN
GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN. HE WAS ALSO
CHAIR OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AREA BOARD. HE WAS
VERY PROUD OF THE SERVICES THE
MARINE. HE WAS A STAFF SERGEANT
MARINE CORPS AND WAS INVOLVED IN
THE CLERGY FOUND THAT IS ANOTHER
WAY TO SERVE OTHERS HE WAS
ORDAINED AS A PERMANENT DEACON
IN THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO. HE ON
SPOTTING THESE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
HAD A VERY HUMBLE SPIRIT- HE WAS
ALWAYS THERE FOR OTHERS. EITHER
BOTTOM UP CHEER THEM ON REGALE
THEM WITH STORIES FROM HIS
CHILDHOOD OR STORIES OF HIS
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN THE
LEGISLATURE HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS LOVING WIFE JEAN OF OVER
FIFTY YEARS. HE WAS INCREDIBLY
PROUD OF HIS CHILDREN I KNOW
THAT FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCES
SON PATRICK WHO MANY OF YOU
KNOW. THE SUN ROBERT SADLY
DECEASED DAUGHTER ERIN AND SON
MICHAEL HE ALSO LEAVES BEHIND
FOUR GRANDCHILDREN CHLOE JOSEPH
NOR AND JACK. USABLE DEVOTED
BROTHER TO SIX SIBLINGS AND IS
SURVIVED BY MANY NIECES AND
NEPHEWS- SOME OF US MAY BE ONLY
A VERY FEW REMEMBER HIS FATHER
JACK CANNING WHO SERVED AS
UNDERSECRETARY OF LABOR UNDER
PRESIDENT KENNEDY. IS INVESTED
IN NEW ZEALAND UNDER PRESIDENT
JOHNSON IS EXECUTIVE SECRETARY
TREASURER OF THE STATE LABOR
FEDERATION FOR TWENTY SIX YEARS
. PATRICK SAID THAT HIS FATHER
JACK. TAUGHT HIM THAT THE
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN ARE THE
BACKBONE OF THIS COUNTRY AND
THEY OUGHT TO BE RECOGNIZED FOR
THE CONTRIBUTIONS. AND IT IS
APPROPRIATE THAT WE THE STATE
CENTER HONOR HIM. FOR HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS THE CITY
CALIFORNIA AS YOU JOIN IN
REMEMBERING PATRICK W. HENNING
SENIOR. THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF. THANK YOU-MR CHAIRMAN LADIES DOWN THE
CENTER I HAVE ALSO RISE TO HONOR
THAT KNOWLEDGE PATRICK SERVICE.
I GO WAY BACK TO THE TENURE OF
HIS LEGENDARY FATHER JACK AND.
AND THOUGH I DIDN'T AGREE WITH
THE UNION MOVEMENT AND MANY
ISSUES THE ONE IN COMMON THAT WE
ALWAYS AGREED ON THOSE JOBS.
OFTENTIMES IN THE ELECTIONS THE
LOCAL AFL-CIO UNIONS WOULD
ENDORSE ME THEN WHEN YOU GET TO
THE JACKS LEVEL I NEED SAY NO.
THAT IS NOT MY POINT. THE POINT
IS HOW MUCH I RESPECTED HIS AND
HIS SON'S PASSIONATE. INTEREST
IN THE WORKING MEN AND WOMEN OF
CALIFORNIA. THEY CLEARLY HAD HIM
IN THEIR HEARTS IT'S CLEARLY AND
PASSIONATELY SUPPORTED THOSE
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN AND MAKING
THEIR LIVES BETTER. THOUGH WE
WERE ADVERSARIAL ON SOME POINTS
THEY WERE BOTH ALWAYS GENTLEMAN
EASY TO DEAL WITH. AND PAT
REPRESENTED HIS UNIONS WITH A
PASSION AND CONVICTION. AND ALL
OF HIS HEART. THIS IS A PASSION
OF A KIND OF A LEGENDARY
LEADERSHIP. FAMILIAL HISTORY THE
LABOR MOVEMENT OF CALIFORNIA.
THESE TWO MEN MADE THEIR MARK ON
THE LABOR MOVEMENT AND ON THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA I WILL
GRIEVE HIS LOSS PRAISE GOD FOR
HIS SOUL. THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF
THE CONFERENCE- WE HAVE SENATOR
DRAWS ALSO WHO WANTS TO RETURN
MEMORY ON. MR IN THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- NOT MORE MUCH MORE I
COULD ADD TO MY COLLEAGUES IN
THEIR REMARKS BUT I FEEL IT'S OF
HUGE RESPONSIBILITY TO- JUST SAY
THAT BOTH MR JACK CANNING AS
WELL AS PATRICK- AND THEIR
ENTIRE FAMILY LEFT A MARK ON THE
LABOR MOVEMENT. ON WERE
EXTRAORDINARY LEADERS AND VERY
VERY PASSIONATE AND
COMPASSIONATE SO I'M VERY LUCKY
THAT I IN THE START OF MY LABOR
CAREER THAT I WAS ABLE TO MEET
ANNA AND KIND OF HANG OUT WITH
MISTER JACK CANNING AND ALSO
WITH WITH PATRICK SO I JUST WANT
TO ADD MY VOICE TO THIS
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE
EXTEND OUR SINCERE CONDOLENCES
AND WE ASK THAT YOU BRING THE
NAME FORD SO MISTER AND CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. EXCEPT
PRESIDENT OUR COLLEAGUES TODAY I
RISE- SAT WITH A LOT OF SADNESS
ACCOUNTS OF THE SENATE ADJOURNED
IN MEMORY. OF RICHARD MCGARY A
VERY LONG TIME- RESIDENTS OF THE
CASTRO ONE OF US TO PARK. AREA I
SEE THE NEIGHBORHOOD THAT I.
LIVE IN- ISSUE IS A LONG TIME-
WAS A LONG TIME- A PILLAR OF
OUR- ACCOUNTS TO OUR COMMUNITY-
AND A FRIEND AND SOMEONE WHO I
PERSONALLY ADMIRED- GREATLY. I
RICHARD WAS BORN ON NOVEMBER
FOURTH NINETEEN FORTY IN NEW
YORK. HIS FAMILY RELOCATED TO
PASADENA IN NINETEEN FORTY
THREE- HE THEN RELOCATED TO SAN
FRANCISCO TO ATTEND THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
RIGHT AFTER GRADUATING FROM USF
WITH A DEGREE IN ECONOMICS.
RICHARD WENT TO WORK- FOR BANK
OF AMERICA WHERE HE BECAME A
SPECIALIST- AND LOANS TO
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES. HE
ALSO ERVED AS CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER FOR AMERICAN SHARED
HOSPITAL SERVICES. WHICH WAS THE
FIRST COMPANY TO LEASE MOBILE CT
SCAN UNITS. HOSPITALS ACROSS THE
WESTERN US. ALAINA RICH HOW THE
MOST DID I WAS THAT HE- AND-
PORTION OF HIS LIFE- TO HIS
COMMUNITY. AS AN ORGANIZER AS A
VOLUNTEER. AS A LEADER- BUT NOT
NOT ALWAYS A LEADER WHO HAD THE
TITLE BUT SOMEONE WHO LEADS BY
THE WORK THAT HE DID- SHE- SPENT
FIFTEEN YEARS AS THE
ADMINISTRATOR FOR OUR CUSTOMER
CAN SOCIAIS ASIAN- HIS SYSTEM
INVOLVED IN PRETTY MUCH EVERY
ASPECT OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD IN A
VERY QUIET. AND EFFECTIVE WAY-
FROM THE LARGE THINGS TO THE
SMALL THINGS WE HAVE A MEETING
ROOM AND THE CASTRO THAT'S
DEDICATED TO THE COMMUNITY FOR
COMMUNITY MEETINGS- AND RICHARD.
MADISON ORGANIZE THAT ROOM FOR
MANY YEARS ONE OF THOSE VERY
QUIET THINGS OFFICERS TO HELP
THE COMMUNITY OF FUNCTIONS HE
PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN OUR- ANNUAL
CASTER GUIDE- HE PUT TOGETHER A
HOLIDAY PARTIES IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD- HE HELPED MANAGE-
THE RAINBOW FLAG THE ACCOUNT FOR
A MARKET IF ANYONE HAS SEEN THE
ENORMOUS. ACCOUNTS FOR FLAGS
RICHARD HELPED OUT WITH THAT. HE
ALSO- SPENT MANY YEARS- TWENTY
FIVE SPECIFICALLY- AS PRESIDENT
OF THE POINT OF THIS-
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION AND
ANYONE WHO HAS EVER SERVED AS A
PRESIDENT OF A NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION NO THAT IS NOT EASY
YOU'RE ALWAYS IN THE MIDDLE OF
EVERY CONTROVERSY- BUT HE DID
THAT ROLE AND HE- DID IT WITH
ABSOLUTE. GRACE AND DURING HIS
TIME- A LOT OF WORK HAPPENED TO
REALLY RUN TO BE- BONAVISTA PARK
WHICH IS AN AMAZING. YOU PARK
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE DECEMBER SO
THAT FALLEN SOME BAD- AND
RICHARD OPEN ROLLING- TO RUN-
THAT BEAUTIFUL COMMUNITY
TREASURE. HI RICHARD SURVIVED BY
A SISTER BY NIECES AND NEPHEWS
AND THEIR FAMILIES- HIS PASSING
IS A HUGE LOSS TO OUR COMMUNITY-
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
SENATE ADJOURNED. IN HIS MEMORY
. THANK YOU SENATOR WARNER.
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE
EXTEND OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
TO. THE MCCURRY FAMILY WE ASK
THAT YOU BRING THE NAME FORGERY
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. IF
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS CENTER
I CAN SUGGEST IS CLEAR. I THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR THIS
THURSDAY MARCH THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AT NINE AM. THANK YOU
. MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME AN ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY AT NINE AM.